la expresión 5 por 2 a la te indica el
número de hojas en una planta como
función del número de semanas desde que
la planta fue sembrada que representa el
2 en esta expresión y como siempre nos
invitó a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta
muy bien veamos esta expresión de aquí
podemos escribirla como si estuviéramos
definiendo una función el número de
hojas como función del tiempo es igual a
5 por 2 a la t ahora digamos que
queremos saber cuál es el valor de esta
función cuando t es igual a 0 es decir
en la semana en la que se sembró esta
planta pues esto es igual a 5 por 2 a la
0 2 a la 0 es 1 por lo que esto es igual
a 5 cuando vemos una expresión o función
exponencial como ésta con frecuencia nos
referimos a este número de acá como el
valor inicial valor inicial exploremos
esto un poco más
sigamos analizando esto a que es igual
esta función
después de que pasó una semana esto será
igual a 5 x 2
la potencia o 5 por 2 así que desde que
fue sembrada esta planta hasta la
primera semana el número de hojas se
multiplicó por 2 así que este se duplica
y qué pasa cuando pasaron dos semanas
pues esto es igual a 5 por 2 a la
segunda potencia que es el número que
teníamos en la primera semana
multiplicado por dos así que parece que
cada semana el número de hojas se
multiplica por 2 y es por eso que este
número de aquí que es el 2 al que se
refiere esta pregunta frecuentemente nos
referimos a esto como la proporción
común ya que entre cualquier par de
semanas consecutivas la proporción entre
digamos la semana 2 y la semana 1 se va
a duplicar la semana 2 es el doble de la
semana 1 la semana 1 es el doble de la
semana 0 veamos cuál de estas opciones
coincide con esto la planta tenía dos
hojas desde el principio esto no se
cumple ya que vimos que el valor inicial
es 5 esta no es la opción correcta la
segunda opción es el número de hojas es
multiplicado por 2 cada semana esto es
justamente lo que acabamos de describir
esta parece ser la opción correcta pero
veamos la siguiente opción por no dejar
la planta fue sembrada hace dos semanas
pues no no nos están diciendo nada al
respecto esta es una expresión general
para tres semanas después de que fue
sembrada no nos dicen cuándo fue
sembrada esta planta así que descartamos
esta opción y confirmamos que la segunda
opción es la correcta